yo why why did you have to knock out our
boy Alain bro that was rude that was
[__] up honestly I with I do too I
felt bad did you really I uh I do feel
badish now cuz I do I think he's a good
dude um but it just had to be done
that's interesting hold on I do feel bad
genuinely does that happen you build up
this animosity for somebody cuz you're
going to fight them and then afterwards
they turn out to be a good guy I never
honestly had animosity with Alo always I
always thought he was a good dude I
never really talked like too much [__]
going into it he was always kind of comp
M I think you know I think he's a good
dude Cheeto I don't like him I'm EXC
tell you guys do not like each other we
Face to Face Tomorrow do face to face
tomorrow I thought you guys weren't
doing face to face no you weren't doing
press conference you said we not doing
press conference we were yeah I thought
we were going to do a press conference I
didn't know when they were going to
release it I was coming to New York due
all this media but I kept telling UFC
I'm like I don't every media I do it's
like when's your next fight and they we
weren't going to announce it I was like
we have to [__] announce it we have
to I can't not do all this media all
week and not able to so they yeah they I
didn't even know Dana was going to I I
was sitting in Ariel's green room and uh
I was looking through my Snapchat
comments and uh they're like is March is
March serious what I went and saw that
Dana announced it Cheeto didn't even
know until he facetimed Ariel he he
probably knew like I
knew wrest haircut looks great by the
way some sorry about that yeah yeah yeah
I mean you look great too that was a
great text message you made up from
Cheeto though that was made up wait he
he said he I he said Cheeto message me
and he was like read the text for Weir
yeah let's see if it matches
up he said hey bro thank you for he
spell hey ha A Y did he yeah why he hey
bro thank you for choosing me for my
next fight our last fight I got so lucky
LOL it's crazy you were kicking my ass
LOL damn yeah that's crazy why would he
text you that I don't know yo can I ask
you a question yeah do you think Cheeto
is the best dressed in the UFC stop I'm
being dead serious Cheo has fantastic
styles conversation last time I don't
know what you have with Cheeto I don't
know if you guys have like my man has
great style he looks good can we pull up
some
IM you look great too nothing it has
nothing to do with me wanting to you
know knock his ass out I just genuinely
don't look at him be like I think it's
[__] up what you do to Gotham City on
a day-to-day basis but I like that is
kind of [__] up you really think he
dress is nice huh no [__] I think he
has great style for like what I mean not
to be a
kaleidoscope
but come on try it act out [__] okay
let me act it out let me act out you got
Top Ramen on your
head that a hit no I just think he has
great style I think he is great style
it's different it's different than what
you're doing who do you think has good
style other than other than you who
other than you has good style in us um
obviously Conor dresses he he looks good
he [__] dresses nice um I'm not into
Conor style I'm not as I meant to Conor
but the style I don't yeah so
G I just like him like him as a man know
I like him for what's on the inside I
didn't know talking about fashion would
get gayer but we got it there I like his
accent not sure um I don't think yeah I
just I'm on a different level when it
comes to the style I think I just don't
really think anyone's that close to be
honest I see these winds on you you
shining out
here brighter than the last time how
much is the watch 180 200 on a good day
he didn't like my other one so I had to
switch it up but then he got you got
another rich rich rich but he like one
more or still ugly I don't like the
Richard Mills
okay don't let me I I don't like it I
like I like your personality appreciate
that I like the way you fight P Rolex
Flames that was the pink the Rolex is
crazy that one's I I might put that on
AEP can I tell you a prediction that I
had about that after we were did our
fake sparring yeah for me yeah okay what
uh I think I even said on the Pod but uh
I I was like hey guys you know there's
one thing sugar Shan and I have in
common only one probably on the entire
planet and that's if we both [__] with
[__] with prize picks and if you use
the promo code Schultz at sign up at
prize picks they'll match your initial
deposit up to $100 that means if you put
in1 you get $100 for free you're already
winning and if you're listening to the
akos locks you might be winning you
might also be losing priz picks.com
promo Cod Schultz let's get back to the
show you get this crazy extension when
you throw straight punches and like your
whole body twists you know how like
sometimes people like they'll barely
even move or they'll just extend arms
yeah like Cheeto oh is that how is that
how he throws yeah he's slow and I
remember being in there with you and I'm
like taller I'm like significantly
taller than you I'm like so much tall
like I'm like huge uh and I remember
just being there like wow like
distance-wise without even moving in
you could touch me whenever you wanted
yeah and in that moment I was like aljo
better not keep this on the feet M he
better not keep this on the feet
couldn't take down not take down were
you were you surprised about that um and
was that like a big confidence booster
it was huge it was huge he was I I look
at him as the best grab he was the
hardest matchup in in in the band
division for 100% and uh stuff both his
takedowns yeah yeah so that was a huge
confidence booster I knew I was capable
of it
um but to go out there and do it in the
moment when it matters that's huge okay
I want to see that rematch let me ask
you this question really how am I
supposed to one up that he that he's not
like popular there's so many other guys
that are like bigger
fights me vers Cheeto me you vers Cheeto
is huge yeah and then what else me vers
Cory is a bigger fight people are
excited about that I mean just from a
technicals Umar someday if he goes out
there and gets a couple wins just Umar n
mamedov versus sha Ali that's Conor
y yeah but he's got to get some wins I
feel like there not as much interest
he's probably going to get some if he
can get to fights healthy uh Elia Toria
versus Alexander volkanovski in February
y if Elia goes out there and beats vul I
would like to go up to 45 really so I
think that's a big F you said you don't
really want to fight vul yeah no but he
say he would want to go fight if he wins
if he gets the job done I think vul's
coming back a little too soon really uh
from getting knocked out have you have
you felt uh have you felt what what vul
was talking about ever where you're like
oh yeah what is that I I feel like I I I
don't feel it too much unless I can't
train like deal with injuries like if I
can go out there and train really hard
and grapple and just do like get that
that uh release of that energy out I
feel fine but if I was dealing with like
an injury and you can't train really
hard I feel like that's when I feel it
but and what is what is the feeling I
think it's just not preparing for a
fight just kind of feel like you don't
have a purpose yeah but I think that's
just I mean
I and I've always bring it back to
meditation but I do think there's like
something in that bro that was the other
thing I was surprised about when we were
over when we were in Phoenix hanging
with you guys was uh I think that you
give the
illusion that you're hanging you're
smoking you're beating up the dummy in
the backyard whatever and then I don't
want to give away too much of how the
sausage is made but like you going
through like your regiment how strict it
is the things you're doing for mental
health the things you're doing for
physical health it was yeah it's no
accident yeah no I think it's a good
message to spread and tell people about
but it's not sexy like people aren't if
it was just that people don't follow
that too much yeah so I think uh I like
spreading it out a little bit telling
people about it yeah when there's a good
when there's a platform to put it on
okay champ [__] champ [__] champ [__]
drugs and
[__] more
meditating no I'm kidding chamption the
feeling sensation like walking around
different than next week is is it like
week month like tell me how long it
lasts the high eventually I'm sure you
start to get into okay I have to prepare
for this next fight how long is the high
what is the high like no to be honest I
I was I was I felt I felt like I was
kind of champed before before the belt I
really truly believe I was the biggest
name in the division my fight versus
Peter Yan was huge my fight versus uh
Pedro moo was big didn't play out you
know it was a big uh buildup expectation
for you was always big felt like I was
I've been champed so when I won the belt
in that spectacular fashion though there
was it was nice but as far as like how
did I
feel I just feel like a [__] normal
dude I want to feel cool as [__] and
feel like I'm champ but I just don't not
yet not yet no nothing still feels just
like a I still feel like I have so much
that I need to do I have to defend the
belt I think you need to defend the belt
for your champ you know what I mean so I
I still feel like I have so much to do
and so much I want to accomplish that I
don't feel like uh which is a good thing
I think because if I felt like I'm like
I did it I [__] did it and didn't
have that drive anymore that's dangerous
dangerous so I haven't checked out yet I
feel like I'll know when I check out
what about was there like a moment with
you I got to bring him his ass down all
the time Coach of the Year walking
around [__] man yeah that's why we told
him he's not invited he wanted to come
he was invited but then we had to
uninvite him yeah he need he needs
[__] reality Che coffee shop he was
great in the uh what the flower Moon
thing kill
fantastic that new Martin SC Daisy movie
he's [__] fantastic you didn't know
your boy was in that movie yeah he was
in Breaking Bad he's been Friday that
night he
all you didn't know [__] Matt Damon
is your coach I could see I get
[__] no Tim's been doing good he's
opening up a second Gym little coffee
coffee shop just his Gym's right here
and then right down the hall there's
another space he's opening up a little
gym little coffee shop he wanted to come
but his second gym just opened so it was
like super hectic shout out Tim Tim's a
[__] man yeah we got to get him
got to get a on okay okay okay okay okay
so you're not on this like super crazy
high from
it tell me that's not shout out that's
like a better looking version of Tim
yeah eyes a little Clos Tim what he
wishes he looked like yeah oh no that
guy Jesse plens